and equals and sub 0 times 1/2 raised to
the T over the half-life so let's just
break that down and Sub Zero means the
amount at time 0 the original amount 1/2
is your base because it's cutting in
half every T divided by the half-life so
T is the time and half-life is the time
that it takes for it to break down and
end up just with half of the original
amount and then n here is what you end
up with after that amount of time so
let's look at an example it says you
have 100 grams of a substance that has a
half-life of 20 days okay so it takes 20
days for it to cut into half or break
down to half how long will it take for
you to have 10 grams remaining okay so
let's see if we can use the formula here
we're starting with let's see 100 grams
okay
1/2 we're trying to figure out the time
that it takes the half-life is let's see
20 days and we want to end up with just
10 grams so that's 10 okay so we're
trying to solve for T so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna work from the
outside in towards the T by doing the
opposite operation so first I'm going to
do is divide both sides by 100 and if we
do that we get point 1 0 equals 1/2 to
the T over 20 now because the variables
in the exponent position we're gonna do
the opposite of exponentiating we're
going to take the logarithm of both
sides so because this is base 1/2 let's
take the log base 1/2 of this quantity
here 1/2 to the T over 20 and we're
gonna do the same thing to the left side
of the equation because we want to keep
it balanced right these are inverses
they cancel one another out or undo one
another so you're left with T divided by
20 equals log base 1/2 of a point one
zero we're just going to do the opposite
of dividing by 20 multiply both sides by
20 to get T by itself let's do the same
thing to the other side and let's go to
the calculator now but a lot of
calculators don't have the ability to
take the log base 1/2 they only have the
common log base 10 and the natural log
so we can use the change of base formula
by taking the natural log of 0.1 0 over
the natural log of 1/2 which is 0.5 and
then multiply that whole quantity times
20 that will give us our time so let's
go to the calculator let's see what we
get you can double check me here we've
got natural log of 0.1 0 divided by
natural log
point five times twenty sixty six point
four days so that's the time T equals
sixty six point four days and that's how
long it will take to go from 100 grams
initially to 10 grams remaining so I
hope this helps you to understand how to
work with the half-life problems a
little bit easier this is the forming
you're going to want to use or memorize
here
subscribe to the channel check out some
of the other math videos that I have on
Mario's math tutor and YouTube channel
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon